today i want to discuss
nucleic acid metabolism but before
getting to that i want to
take a step back and talk a bit about
what we closed with last time which was
discussing serine glycine metabolism and
how they can be used to generate
one carbon units that are for
one carbon transfer reactions and these
are one carbon transfer reactions
moving carbon that's more reduced than
co2
you'll remember if we're going to do a
carboxylation reaction transfer co2 that
often used biotin
whereas if you're transferring a one
carbon unit that's more reduced than co2
it comes from these folate species and
we described some of the different
folate species
n5 methyl thf which can donate
a fully reduced one carbon unit a methyl
group to sam
sam being the universal methyl donor for
most methylation reactions in cells
you can also have folates carry more
oxidized one carbon units n5n10
methylene thf
n10 formal thf and those will be very
important today
as we discuss um one carbon transfer
reactions
in nucleotide synthesis now i recognize
that folate metabolism can be very
confusing the structures are complex the
names are long and
convoluted and hard to you know
incorporate but if you can think of it
as just
transferring one carbon units of a
different oxidation
state hopefully that will help you
better understand what's going on
in folate reactions and so really all it
is remember
serine has three carbons glycine has two
carbons
and so when you convert serine to
glycine
you end up generating a one carbon unit
as i showed you in the lecture last time
this one carbon unit
is in the formaldehyde oxidation state
and so ultimately that's generated
that's donated to a folate species
to generate this carrier the n5n10
methylene
thf which you can really think of
as a carrier for
one carbon unit in the formaldehyde
oxidation state
okay now those can undergo
an oxidation reaction okay
and so if we oxidize that carbon
from the aldehyde to the acid okay now
we end up getting the
n10 formal
thf all right so that's carrying
the one carbon unit
as the acid all right
or we can reduce
that one carbon unit to the methyl group
and that's carrying it as the n5
methyl
thf okay so carrying this as a
methyl group more reduced carbon um
than where we started and so try to cut
through all the names and whatnot and
just realize
that it's simply transfers of carbon in
different oxidation states
and the relevant ones today is going to
be n10 formal and
n5n10 methylene thf because it turns out
generating those
oxidized one carbon units uh four make
groups etc
is going to be important for um
purine as well as thymine synthesis
okay so
our topic today is really to discuss
how we generate nucleic acids how we
break down
purines and pyrimidines or peerings
and this is really the final topic here
in the course
in some ways it's a bit fitting because
it really
incorporates lots of aspects of
metabolism that we've been discussing
over the course of semester all come
together
in nucleotide metabolism now
nucleotide metabolism itself is a very
large topic
um probably deserves more than
one 90-minute lecture but
unfortunately the time is what it is and
we just don't have time to cover
every single detail however we can go
pretty fast and at least give you a
flavor of what's going on
because you know as i've alluded to this
draws to lots of metabolism i drew here
just a very
skeletonized view of glycolysis the tca
cycle the pentose phosphate pathway
a couple aspects of amino acid synthesis
folate metabolism
and drew boxes around all the precursors
that are necessary to generate
various nucleotides and you can see it's
really drawn from across
these metabolic pathways as we go
through these
you'll see that you actually know a lot
and this synthesizes really
what we've learned from lots of other
pathways coming together
into into understanding how cells make
purines and pyrimidines now
down here i've color-coded all the
different so here's a pyrimidine here's
appearing
the ring structure that you're probably
familiar with from these purines and
pyrimidines
and color-coded where it is that each of
these atoms come from where they're
drawn from
across uh you know you know across um
uh metabolism and again it's a nice way
to sort of synthesize
lots of the pathways that we've
discussed in class
now ribose also is going to come from
ribose 5-phosphate that's of course a
product of the pentose phosphate pathway
oxidative or non-oxidative depending on
how the cell wants to use those pathways
the calvin cycle and photosynthesis lots
of ways to get ribose 5-phosphate
that generates the ribose and then
there's a lot of
complexity that goes into how one builds
these
um complex base structures
now we just want to start here and show
you
on the slide here here's a you know
general purine base here's a general
pyrimidine base
um kind of a stupid mnemonic that's
always helped me
that maybe will help you if you need to
remember which of these is the purine
and which of these is the pyrimidine as
you go through
you know take mcat exams or something
like that
so the purine ring looks kind of like a
pope hat
and the pope is pure and so it's kind of
stupid but it's one way to remember
that this pope hat looking structure is
the purine
and the other one is the is the
pyrimidine
um of course you're familiar with
purines and pyrimidines because
these generate the various bases that
are used for rna and dna so adenine and
guanine the two
purine bases and rna and dna and then
cytosine and uracil and rna and cytosine
and thymine
in in dna
are the pyrimidine bases in rna and dna
now these are of course not the only
possible purines and pyrimidines they're
not the only purines and pyrimidines
that nature cares about
um you know here's a few other ones
shown here and so
uh you know here's uric acid uric acid
as we've
discussed is the way birds excrete
nitrogen we'll discuss later today that
it's the cause of gout a very common
human condition there's also lots of
other pharmacologically active molecules
among the purines and pyrimidines so
here's caffeine certainly a very
important molecule for
many of us to get going in the morning
there's things like adenine so adenine
plus the ribose sugars a molecule called
adenosine
adenosine is a very important signaling
molecule in our bodies if you
go to medical school you'll use
adenosine to
to figure out people's heart rhythms
there's also lots of drugs that come
from purines and pyrimidines so here's
an example here this is the drug
5-fluorouracil
a widely used cancer drug and so it's an
analog
of a pyrimidine lots of
anti-cancer drugs as well as
antimicrobials end up being
you know drugs that interfere with
nucleotide metabolism
and often are analogues of
purines and pyrimidines now
the first general comment i want to make
is that in cells the free bases of these
things are
much less useful than the nucleosides
and the nucleotides
and so just to remind you of a little
bit of nomenclature
is that you know these purine and
pyrimidine bases
are usually attached to ribose and a
nucleoside
okay so a nucleoside is basically
the base period and pyrimidine base plus
ribose
but no phosphate all right so adenosine
would be adenine stuck to ribose but no
phosphates on it that's adenosine
and then you have your nucleotides
and the nucleotides are the base plus
the ribose
plus phosphate and so it can be
nucleotide monophosphate diphosphate
triphosphate amp
adp atp examples of
nucleotides now there are
two major ways that cells build
nucleotides okay um and that is
they can you know make them
de novo all right so de novo
is building them from scratch all right
or you'll see that they can
so-called salvage the bases
and this is you might imagine that if as
animals we eat other organisms we take
in their rna and dna we get some of
these
um purine and pyrimidine bases that
these can be
salvaged that is re-added back to ribose
uh to generate nucleosides and
nucleotides
and you'll see as we go through how you
do de novo synthesis that making these
things
is complex it's energetically expensive
and so of course salvaging
prevents you having to expend this
energy and effort in order to generate
them
de novo i also want to remind you
because it's evident in the fact that
uric acid is a way that birds and
reptiles can excrete nitrogen
is that just back to our prior
discussion that
in the world in the biosphere nitrogen
is a precious commodity remember it has
to be fixed it's not
infinitely available relatively few
organisms can fix nitrogen
into its usable form and so salvaging
pre-made bases is
salvaging nitrate salvaging nitrogen in
a usable form
and so evolutionarily for a lot of
organisms that's also a beneficial
thing to do all right
now another
last sort of introductory comment about
why
this lecture ends up being important and
having some appreciation of these
pathways
is that certainly if you go to medical
school you will
come across all kinds of things having
to do with
the metabolism of today's lecture and
that's because it turns out that making
nucleosides
making nucleotides is limiting for
proliferation
in all kinds of biological contexts all
right and this is really back to what i
alluded to earlier a lot of our
anti-cancer drugs they also end up being
anti-inflammatory so things to treat
inflammatory diseases and cancer
oftentimes are
things that block steps in nucleotide
metabolism
lots of antimicrobials or antibiotics
also attack some of the same pathways
but are more specific for bacterial
rather than human
enzymes and so
really these drugs converge on pathways
that either produce or salvage
nucleotides and it's
good to have some appreciation of where
these things are acting
because this ends up being really
important for
all kinds of aspects of of human
medicine as well as understanding
other bits of biology all right
now either de novo synthesis
of purine and pyrimidine nucleotides
or salvage of those thing of
purine and pyrimidine nucleotides needs
to add the base
somehow to a ribose and that starts
with generating a molecule called prpp
also abbreviated up there in my general
overview
this stands for poly
ribo
sorry stands for phospho
ribose pyrophosphate
okay p-r-p-p
phosphoribose pyrophosphate so what is
that
well this is if we draw here
our ribose sugar
and we draw it in the
alpha firinos form so this would be
alpha five
ribose phosphate okay so
sorry alpha ribose biphosphate
okay so that's ribose 5-phosphate that's
generated from
pentose phosphate pathway generated from
the calvin cycle
whatever this is uh really
starting point discuss lots of ways we
can generate that
um through different pathways well
if we take atp
and convert it to amp that is
transfer two phosphates
pyrophosphorylate the one position
now we end up with this molecule
okay so this molecule here
would be prpp
so phosphoribo pyrophosphate
and prpp can pick up a nitrogen
either the nitrogen
from the base if it's the salvage
pathway
or whatever nitrogen containing molecule
is going to be the first step in de novo
synthesis which we'll get to later
and basically releases the
pyrophosphate that can be cleaved
to two inorganic phosphates pull the
reaction forward
and what one ends up with
is
basically this
nitrogen added either as
the nucleoside monophosphate
or some precursor to nitrogen containing
precursor to the nucleoside
monophosphate
that we can then build the purine or
pyrimidine base on top
all right and so
the dogma is is that de novo synthesis
of nucleotides is important for new
proliferation of cells whereas salvage
is important for maintenance of cells
this is a huge oversimplification it's
effectively untrue as far as i'm
concerned lots of drugs
that affect salvage can affect diseases
involved in proliferation and whatnot
but nonetheless you should just realize
that
these early steps that is adding prpp
is important either to salvage things or
to do de novo synthesis
now today given our limited amount of
time
i'm really going to focus on de novo
synthesis of purines and pyrimidines i
will discuss a little bit about
purine catabolism mainly this is because
these are the most
topics where there's something to say
about biochemistry and metabolism that
builds off
a lot of the themes that we've covered
in the class they also
focus on lots of aspects of relevant
medicine
and so those of you who go to medical
school we'll see this again and i want
you to appreciate it a little bit
and particularly some aspects of salvage
are important in biology
and medicine but really my goal today is
not for you to
understand absolutely every chemical
step
that goes on but really to appreciate
how these things happen and hopefully
synthesize some of what you've learned
over the course of the semester
all right so let's talk first about how
you make
purines purine synthesis so
purine synthesis uh you should know your
mit history
so the purine synthesis pathway the de
novo that is building purines from
scratch
was largely worked out by a guy by the
name of jack buchanan
he partially did this at mit
he basically was recruited from
elsewhere came to mit
and when he was at mit also was the
person who really modernized the mit
biology department to be
what it is today so prior to jack
buchanan
biology department was much more about
ecology
and you know things like that and really
he
moved the mit biology department into
the molecular
era and so
for the mit students it's good for you
to
appreciate some of our history all right
now purine synthesis as i said i'm going
to go through
all the steps of purine synthesis you'll
see it's complicated
all right um i will show you some of the
chemistry i don't have time to go into a
great detail
or explain all the steps in great detail
but again my goal here is for you to
appreciate how purines are made
not necessarily memorize all the steps
in the pathway all right so
purine synthesis starts with
phosphoribose pyrophosphate
okay we're going to build on the
ribose base and the first step
is taking glutamine
and converting it to glutamate so what
is that
transferring that's transferring a
nitrogen okay remember the difference
between glutamine and glutamate you can
pick that up with glutamine synthase
is um that was one way to put an ammonia
onto glutamate to make glutamine and so
this ends up carrying out the reaction
that
i showed you earlier
and adds
a nitrogen to the ribose
sugar giving you this compound
all right the next step is to
take a glycine molecule and that glycine
molecule
gets phosphorylated with atp
okay so phosphorylate the carboxylic
acid on
the glycine molecule and then this
will
combined with the um
the prior molecule releasing
phosphate and generating this molecule
which i'm now going to just draw
draw phosphoribose as
like that because drawing ribose over
and over again will become
painful um
and that generates this intermediate
which is called
glycinamide
ribo
nucleotide i'm not going to write out
nucleotide and you will see
that many of the steps in purine
synthesis
end up having these abbreviations this
one is called
gar for glycemide ribonucleotide
and you'll see as we get these long
complex names why
one uses these abbreviations like gar
which are actually
used quite commonly
all right the next step is we're going
to
add a one carbon unit
a formate group so remember the formate
carrier comes from n10
n10 formal thf all right
and so
oops my eraser
going to come from n10 formal thf
all right so this is
that's going to take the one carbon unit
off to regenerate thf which of course
can pick up the one carbonyl
unit again from serine and glycine and
then undergo an oxidation reaction to
get the
the format group the n10 formal thf
and that generates this intermediate
which is called fgar
for formal gar so
formal glycemide um ribonucleotide or
fgar all right the next step
is we're going to add
a nitro basically swap
this um oxygen here
on this carbonyl to a nitrogen so a c
double bond to a nitrogen bond and
that requires so that's going to come
from glutamine
again and it requires atp
and it's somewhat of a complex reaction
and i think it's
again i will show you very briefly how
this works if you don't follow all of it
don't worry about it
but basically if we just draw the
middle part here of the molecule all
right i don't want to draw out the whole
thing
so basically this is phosphorylation
here so the phosphate from atp
transferred here to give this
intermediate
that will lose a water
giving
giving this intermediate then
the ammonia from glutamine
to glutamate
come here release the uh
the phosphate
okay and then typically this is
drawn where we just rearrange the double
bond
and one ends up with
this intermediate
which is called fgam
okay so this is this intermediate which
is
gam for formal
glycine amide
ribo nucleotide
okay so afghan
all right makes sense
all right the next reaction
is also a little bit
complex and maybe hard to see
again i will draw it out if you don't
follow all of it don't worry about it
but
it's nice for those of you who want to
follow it to see what's happening
so again now we're going to take another
atp
hydrolyze it to adp plus pi
release a water and in the end what
we're going to generate
is we're going to close
this ring
to generate so we're going to close that
ring so make a bond from this nitrogen
to this carbon
close this ring this generates this
intermediate called
air okay or amino
ribo sorry amino
imidazole
ribo nucleotide
okay don't worry about the long names
everyone would just call it
air so how does this happen well it
happens
as follows
so
first step is phosphorylation of
so atp will phosphorylate the aldehyde
to give this intermediate
water is lost
okay now you have
this nitrogen
down here can
losing the phosphate
okay so that will end up
closing the ring on
that side of the molecule and then all
i've done is i've just removed
the electrons here so that rather than
being a carbon
nitrogen double bond it's now a carbon
carbon double bond
and that generates fgam to air costing
an atp again one of the more complicated
reactions to c again if you're into how
the reactions work
hopefully i gave you enough information
to understand it
if you're not just realize that this is
the next
step okay
the next step is a reaction that's very
similar to one that we saw in the urea
cycle
and that is we are going to add
um oh sorry the next step is
um one that sorry before we do
that step the next step is one where
we're going to add a
we're going to add a co2 group to this
carbon so that's a
carboxylation reaction you would
typically think of a carboxylation
reaction
to involve biotin this is one that
doesn't it's an exception to that rule
does not
involve biotin but it does involve
atp
okay
so remember the way we did this before
is we would have phosphorylation
of our bicarbonate okay so use atp to
phosphorylate
bicarbonate and
okay so if we just draw this part of the
molecule
here
displacing the phosphate and then what
we end up with
is
okay we end up with that and if i just
rearrange that the double bond is here
instead of there
then we end up with this next
intermediate
which is sea
air or carboxy
air okay so sea air
or carboxy air all right now
we get to the step that's very similar
to the one that we saw
in the urea cycle where we're going to
use
aspartate to fumarate conversion to
add a nitrogen to this
carboxylic acid and so you'll
remember that
way we did that in the urea cycle is we
used
atp to amp conversion
to end up adding that aspartate group
in this case it's just atp to adp plus
pi
okay so that's going to phosphorylate
this
acid group okay
okay so i'm not going to draw the whole
thing phosphorylate that and then we'll
have
an aspartate
molecule
okay so this is
the amino acid aspartate
okay and one gets
didn't leave myself enough room but
that's an aspartate molecule bound up
there
to the um to
that carboxylic acid just like we saw
before this is a molecule called
scicar okay which is succinyl
amino
amidazole
carboxy amide
ribo nucleotide
okay definitely everyone calls it
sci-car now just as we saw then from the
urea cycle
we are now going to
take off a fumarate
okay so this is reaction that
you've seen before
okay just like we saw in the urea cycle
so that reaction
lose the fumarate and what you're left
with is
basically just the nitrogen
left behind
okay and
you get this intermediate which is
referred to
as i-car so
amino amidazole carboxyamide
ribonucleotide
so minus the succinate group
icar okay next step
is is we're going to use a
formate group and add it to this
nitrogen so that's
straightforward we
so if we draw out here our formate group
from n10 formal
thf
okay so that will be our n10
formal
thf
generate thf and then we
get
okay then we get that formate group
added
there and so this is
phi car or formal
icar phi car all right
next step is we're going to close
the ring okay
okay and so close
the ring that's going to give this
okay so that part of the molecule where
the ring closes
just rearrange
like that to lose water
and that is going to generate our
oops
our purine ring
the way you're used to
seeing it drawn and so this is the
purine
imp for inocene
monophosphate okay and inosine
monophosphate is the precursor from
all for all purines and so if you
look at this what you see is that in the
end there is two nitrogens that come
from ammonia from glutamine to glutamate
from the ammonia released from glutamine
to glutamate
one nitrogen here that comes from
glycine and that nitrogen there that
comes from aspartate
two of the carbons these two come from
the formate group from n10 formal thf
another carbon up here comes from co2
and the remaining two carbons here come
from a glycine molecule
with of course the ribose phosphate from
prpp and so if you go through what
you'll find is that it took
2 atp to generate the prpp from ribose
phosphate so starting with a ribose
phosphate
two atp to generate the prpp
and then five additional atp so if you
go up and look through all the steps
there are five steps that require atp
so quite a lot of atp to generate
this purine ring in a scene
monophosphate now inosine
is not found in rna or dna and so this
has to be of course
turned into adenine and guanine and so
how does that happen well
i'll show you and so the
turning it inosine monophosphate into
adenine basically involves putting a
nitrogen here instead of this double
bond to oxygen
and so that occurs via a very
similar in fact the same reaction that
we saw
to take um see air
and generate scicar all right
and so it was basically using aspartate
to transfer that nitrogen i don't have
time to go through the whole mechanism
but it's basically what i already
showed you and so you take gtp plus
aspartate get
gdp plus pi note you use
guanine triphosphate so gtp rather than
atp to end up generating the
adenine nucleotide all right
it's going to release water water was
also um released in that reaction
and what you end up with is this
intermediate
so i'm not going to draw the whole
structure for the sake of time
okay but this here would be
the top here of the purine ring
so this would have a
okay so that's going to add an
aspartate molecule up there
and then from that
we're going to release fumarate
okay so fumarate comes off
and what we're left with is
okay and this here is
adenosine monophosphate amp and of
course i can just take
two phosphorylation events and get
atp all right
basically phospho transfer atp to make
adp
and then ultimately adp to make atp via
glycolysis oxidative phosphorylation
whatever and so that's how you generate
adenine nucleotides generate
guanine nucleotides what has to happen
is that we need to um put
a nitrogen here okay so
putting a nitrogen on this carbon first
thing
that happens is we add water
across that double bond okay
so
okay so that's this part here of the
molecule
added water across that double bond
now we're going to oxidize this
carbon nitrogen bond seen this
a million times okay
generates a hydride ion what's that
hydride ion or
sorry oxidize this alcohol
to the ketone so generates a hydride ion
those electrons go to nad plus
generate an nadh oxidation reaction
and that gives us this
okay and then the next step
is is that we're going to take that
ketone
that was generated here and we're going
to
turn it into basically replace that
oxygen
with a nitrogen and so that's exactly
the reaction that we saw
when we went here from fgar to
fgam all right so if i go from
same reaction that i used to go from
fgar to fgam all right so this
is atp
goes to adp plus pi
all right nitrogen comes here from
glutamine to glutamate
okay same reaction that occurs there
water comes off what i end up doing
is i replace this
i'll end up getting this structure
instead
and then i can just rearrange the double
bond to be on the ring rather than to
the nitrogen
offside outside the ring and that
generates
okay and so this is gmp
notice that the atp was used to make gmp
gtp was used to make amp so you use the
opposite purine
to make each reaction i know i went
through these quickly
just don't have time to go into it in
more detail but it's really just
repurposing
similar reactions that are involved in
period synthesis
to end up changing this inosine
monophosphate
into amp or into
gmp and i guess for consistency i should
have drawn that in
yellow because the nitrogen comes from
glutamine
okay so that is purine synthesis that's
how you get amp
and gmp if you're going to
break these things down of course
you're going to use separate pathways
why are you going to use separate
pathways well because
as we've heard over and over again in
the class for thermodynamic reasons
delta g has to be less than zero for any
pathway to work
can't be less than zero in both
directions one direction needs energy
input
i had energy input to make these purine
nucleotides opposite direction don't
need energy
to make it i don't have time to get into
all the details of purine breakdown
although here are some things i just
summarize it
here for you on this slide
basically you start from amp
you take the phosphate off you end up
generating adenosine you end up going to
inocene remove the ribose then you get
another
base and the base on inosine
monophosphate
when it's just the base so the
nucleoside and nucleotide is inescene
when you get rid of the ribose now the
base is called
hypoxampine it's a little bit of a
confusing thing but just recognize that
hypoxanthine is the base
that is found on inosine or inosine
monophosphate
all right and so just to
summarize what i showed you what was on
the slide
so to break down amp you'd
remove the phosphate now you end up with
the nucleoside
adenosine okay so that's adenine plus
the
the ribose
take off the nitrogen to move back to
the nucleoside
in a scene now we can remove
the ribose from inosine what we're left
with
is the base which is hypo
xanthine okay so i'll draw out
hypoxanthine for you here
okay so hypoxanthine you'll see is
basically
exactly what we drew out for innocene
monophosphate it's just the base from
nsc monophosphate
is hypoxanthine now if we oxidize
this carbon nitrogen bond
which is carried out by a
complex oxidation reaction requiring
oxygen and water and producing hydrogen
peroxide
by an enzyme
called xanthine oxidase
okay so the enzyme xanthine oxidase
interesting enzyme has
a molybdenum group and in it as a
cofactor and
iron and fad complex redox reaction we
don't have time to get into
ends up generating this
purine base
okay this purine base is
xanthine okay xanthine
oxidase same enzyme
can also use the same chemistry to
oxidize this nitrogen carbon bond so
this one here went was oxidized there
now we're going to oxidize this one here
and
what does that generate
that generates this compound
uric acid and so for the birds and
reptiles to excrete nitrogen
it would synthesize appearing like amp
and then break it down to uric acid as a
way
to eliminate nitrogen
all right guanine
gmp lose a phosphate
now you get the nucleoside
guanosine okay so guanine the base
plus the ribose with no phosphate
take the ribose group off
now we're left with waning
okay and then if we
start with wanting
remove nitrogen from guanine
then we end up with xanthine okay
so remember there was an additional
oxidation step to make
gmp that wasn't there in amp that means
we get a more oxidized product back when
we break it down so it's broken down to
xanthine
and that can be acted on also to
generate
uric acid and so you could also make gmp
and then break down the gmp to make uric
acid as a way to
excrete nitrogen now uric acid is also
medically important in humans this is of
course the thing that is the cause of
gout so gout is uric acid is produced in
excess
deposits and crystallizes in joints and
causes a lot of pain
and one way to treat gout is with a
xanthine oxidase inhibitor there's a
drug called aloperinol
that inhibits xanthine oxidase and that
ends up being
a way to slow the production of uric
acid and can treat
patients with gout all right
now if you
break down purines and you want to
recapture them
you can also use salvage
and so to save some time here i drew out
basically the salvage pathways for
purines
and so you can start with adenine or you
can start with guanine
or you can start with hypoxanthine and
basically these are simply added to
prpp so if you take adenine add it to
prpp
now you have amp if you take
hypoxanthine
add it to prpp now you have imp and you
can use that imp
to then synthesize amp or not shown here
gmp
which uh by the pathways i've already
shown or if you have guanine you can
salvage that guanine add it to p
prpp and then generate gmp
and so different enzymes do this this
enzyme here
hypoxanthine guanine phosphoribible
transferase which is how you take
guanine or hypoxanthine
and make imp or gmp via salvage pathway
is actually a very famous enzyme
because it's part of an inborn area of
metabolism called lesh
naihan syndrome or hypoguanine
phosphoribol transferase or
hp r
t so hprt deficiency
is what causes lesh naihan
syndrome
and it's an inborn era of metabolism
you're deficient in this
hgprt enzyme which means you can't
salvage guanine or hypoxanthine now
i bring this up not because we have time
to talk about all of
the inborn errors of metabolism but
mentioning this one really points out
that we don't understand metabolism as
well as we think we do
so if i asked you to predict what would
be the consequences of an inability to
salvage guanine and hypoxanthine
you might say oh well that means that
you're going to not be able to take
these things up maybe you'll have
excess guanine and hypoxanthine
breakdown
and maybe you'll get more uric acid and
get gout
and that's absolutely the case patients
with lesh nyhan syndrome hp
rt deficiency do indeed get gout that
makes sense
but the main problem they have is they
have a self-mutilation phenotype they
have a
mental retardation a lot of neurological
stuff
and no one can really explain why it is
that
one gets this complex neurological
phenotype
because you can't salvage guanine and
hypoxanthine the salvage of
purines which again i show here on uh
on a on a slide um really that shows
all of the different enzymes and ways
here's that hprt to salvage
guanine and hypoxanthine to make imp and
gmp
um you know there's actually quite
complex
enzymes that can allow you to basically
interconvert all of these nucleosides
with nucleotides as well as with the
the free base the free purine bases
each of these enzymes has its own
syndrome associated with it
if there's humans that are deficient
some of it causes
immune system problems there's the
mental problems i talked about with hprt
deficiency
again why certain enzymes and pathways
are more important in
specific cells and tissues not so well
understood and really what i want you to
appreciate is that this is complicated
and just realize that this happens
in case you encounter it in your first
future career
and you want to come back and study it
okay
right so we just went through the way
that you can salvage purines or make
purines de novo
and of course that gives you
ribonucleotides that can be used to
generate
rna if you're going to generate dna
you then need to instead of generating
the ribonucleotides
end up with the deoxy ribonucleoside
triphosphates
and what does that mean so if we draw
here here's a
for whatever base adenine guanine
whatever
basically if we're going to generate
a deoxyribonus nucleoside we have to
remember this is the two position of
ribose
and so we need to reduce this two
position of ribose
basically reduce it from the alcohol
to the um to the
saturated hydrocarbon to generate
okay the deoxyribonucleoside
this is carried out by an enzyme
called ribonucleoside
ribonucleotide reductase
makes sense we're doing a redox reaction
reducing that alcohol
to the saturated hybrid hydrocarbon or i
have a nucleotide
reductase interesting mechanism you can
look it up if you're interested
ribonucleotide reductase i drew it this
way on purpose
always acts on the d
ndp so the nucleoside diphosphate
sorry on the nucleoside diphosphate
to generate the deoxy
nucleoside sorry deoxynucleotide
diphosphate so the nucleotide
diphosphate
is what ribonucleotide reductase axon
to generate the um deoxy
nucleotide diphosphate so you would take
adp and generate dadp
gdp and generate d gdp
all right and we'll come back to this in
a minute for pyrimidines
before i get to that i just want to
quickly go through pyrimidine synthesis
and so pyrimidine synthesis is
a lot simpler than purine synthesis
i also like to point out that
pyrimidines are also much less abundant
in cells than purines
so remember atp 10 millimolar
concentration in cells
1 to 10 millimolar gtp somewhere in the
high hundreds of micromolar purines are
more
sorry pyrimidines are more tens of
micromolar and so
orders of magnitude less pyrimidines and
cells
than there are purines and that's
because gtp atp
those are important energy transduction
molecules
we saw a couple places where pyrimidines
can be energy transduction molecules
utp glucose etc but in general most
reactions use
atp and gtp as
energy sources and so
whereas pyrimidines are primarily for
building rna and dna
and so much less abundant in cells all
right
so pyrimidine synthesis
get my colors
so pyrimidine synthesis
starts with carbamyl phosphate
and so you'll remember carbamoyl
phosphate
from the uh
when we discuss the urea cycle okay
so just as a quick reminder so
here's bicarbonate i won't use colors to
start just
for time so if we phosphorylate
bicarbonate okay we ended up
getting this molecule that bicarbonate
we can then
have glutamine
to glutamate conversion that gives us
releases on ammonia that ammonia
can release that phosphate
so atp to adp plus phosphate
and gives us
this molecule which we can phosphorylate
again
to give us
this molecule which is
carbomole phosphate nothing new here
exactly what we showed last time in the
urea cycle
so carbomoyl phosphate
will react with aspartate
okay so here's aspartate
okay the amino acid aspartate
okay and that generates
okay this intermediate
okay so that generates that intermediate
this can now undergo
ring closure like that
and then we end up with
a molecule that looks like
the familiar
ring structure
for a pyrimidine shown here
okay i drew it this way because the next
step so this molecule
is called dihydro
or rotate okay
and the next step is going to be to
oxidize this
carbon-carbon bond if we oxidize
this carbon-carbon bond okay
that gives us hydride ion
oxidizing a carbon-carbon bond just like
we saw in
lipid oxidation just like we saw in
succinate dehydrogenase
this is an fad
as an electron acceptor fad is reduced
to fadh2
this occurs as an alternative to complex
2 in the electron transport chain so
this would occur in the mitochondrial
membrane
and be a way to take dihydro orotate to
orotate
carried out by an enzyme called dihydro
orotate dehydrogenase or dhodh
which ends up forming this alternate
electron transport chain electrons
ultimately ending up as
oxygen and this generates the
base pyrimidine the imp
equivalent if you will of a pyrimidine
which is this molecule
okay which is this molecule called
or rotate and then
orotate will react with
prpp okay
generating a pyrophosphate
which can be cleaved to two inorganic
phosphates
pull the reaction forward and we end up
with this
phospho ribose
um and basically this is going to add to
this nitrogen
right here and so you're used to seeing
it drawn if i add to that nitrogen and
now
rotate the molecule
in that direction
and you get this molecule which is
orotate
monophosphate orotate monophosphate
which is the starting pyrimidine
and simply
decarboxylating orotate
monophosphate will give us
the um
the pyrimidine uridine
monophosphate or ump
okay and so ump
generated um in
that way now to turn
ump into ctp
what happens is ump is
phosphorylated twice so that's going to
cost 2 adp
that's going to generate a utp and then
we're going to take
that utp and carry out again the same
reaction
that you saw earlier for f guard f gam
xanaxan xanthine monophosphate to
guanine monophosphate
okay so i'm going to take glutamine to
glutamate transfer the ammonia
take atp
to adp plus pi and basically what we're
going to end up doing
is changing that
double bond oxygen so double bond there
and an amino group on top
and that is
how we generate
the other major purine
cytodine triphosphate or some other
major pyrimidine cytodine triphosphate
okay
so utp to ctp
reaction that we've already seen before
gets us
ctp now to get
deoxycytodene obviously
remember ribonucleotide reductase acts
on the
diphosphate okay so release a phosphate
so now we have cytodine diphosphate
and now ribonucleotide reductase
can generate deoxycytodene diphosphate
now remember uracil is not used in dna
instead of uracil we use thiamidine so
there's no deoxy uracil or you won't
don't want to make deoxyuracil because
that will
incorporate into dna that's undesirable
and so the way you make
thimodine is you take dcdp
and you further remove a phosphate from
it
and now you get d cmp
and then you take the dcmp and you
convert it
back to d ump
all right converting it back to d u m p
is basically just losing the nitrogen
we've seen that before when we broke
down guanine
okay same reaction dcmp back to d ump
and then dump is a substrate for an
enzyme called
thymodylate synthase
which will take uracil
all right uracil and add a one carbon
unit there
which is a methyl group
as d and generate thimodine
so where does that come from well we're
going to add a methyl group
we could do that from the folate now you
might guess that you'd use 5-methyl thf
for this
but you actually don't instead
what you use is this n5
n10 methyl
methylene thf
which we got directly from serine to
glycine
conversion okay and so this then
is going to add the methyl group
to
we have d u m p
okay so we're gonna add a methyl group
there
and this is going to give me
dtmp all right this is what diamond
delay synthase does
but i've had a methyl group remember
this is
a formaldehyde oxidation state
so if i'm going to add a methyl group
that means that one carbon unit is
getting reduced
when it's being added if it's being
reduced something else has to be
oxidized and the thing that that's
oxidized
is the folate itself so this
is the tetrahydrofolate
is oxidized to instead be a
dihydrofolate okay so double bond
here so that's oxidation that's a
now it becomes dihydrofolate
okay and that dihydrofolate of course
has to be
re-reduced back to the tetrahydro
tetrahydrofolate
and pick up a one carbon unit and so
this comes from nadph
to nadp plus so oxidize nadph
reduce dihydrofolate back to
tetrahydrofolate
pick up another one carbon unit from
serine
to glycine conversion and in the end
this is how you synthesize thymodine
i went through this very quickly but
this is actually a very important
reaction pharmacologically
this is an important target for
antibiotics so
the antibiotic bactrim a very famous
antibiotic
basically blocks this step called
dihydrofolate reductase
okay dihydrofolate reductase dhfr
basically taking dihydrofolate back to
tetrahydrofolate before it can pick up a
serine glycine unit
affects that in the bacteria very
effective antibiotic
okay also anti-folate chemotherapies
methotrexate inhibitor of dihydrofolate
reductase one of the first
chemotherapies ever discovered
also works because it blocks thiamine
synthesis
by preventing your ability to recycle
the dihydrofolate back to
tetrahydrofolate
and carry out thymodine synthesis
and so ends up being a pharmacologically
at least for human medicine
very important series of reactions
all right so for pyrimidine salvage
there's almost nothing to say about it
you just take the primitive bases and
you add it to prpp
and now you have your pyrimidine back um
and so nothing more to say there and
really what i want to do is close
with a few comments about
regulation of nucleoside
and nucleotide metabolism and so
obviously if you're going to synthesize
rna and dna you need to have the right
ratios
of nucleoside of nucleotides
so if your rna polymerase is making an
rna molecule
and it doesn't have the right base
it can't keep going and this is
particularly a problem for dna synthesis
because remember and as you will learn
or have learned in cell biology
you have to license your origins of
replication before you start dna
replication
and that prevents you from ever
replicating the same amount of dna twice
meaning you say here's where you start
and once you start
you can't stop until you finish dna
replication
well this becomes a tremendous problem
if you're trying to replicate your dna
and you run out of nucleosides
or nucleotides and so there has to be
complex mechanisms in place to make sure
that cells
always have the right levels of
nucleotide triphosphates and
deoxynucleoxynucleotide triphosphates
and so there's complex feedbacks that we
could give a whole lecture
on but for the purposes of today i just
want you to be
familiar and know that they're here and
they're also
all make sense they fit exactly with
what we've talked about in other
pathways
and so shown here on the slide is the
control of purine synthesis
and so this makes perfect sense so if
you don't
if you have plenty of purines meaning
you have a lot of
amp gmp imp well what do you do well
don't charge the ribose 5-phosphate to
prpp
or don't carry out the first step in
period synthesis where you take that
ammonia from glutamine and take prpp and
add it to the prpp
to begin period synthesis and so
all of these purine monophosphates
inhibit
this early steps of purine synthesis
makes sense
well what if you have an imbalance in
your amp and gmp pools well
the way you prevent that remember we
already discussed that to turn
imp into amp you use gtp
as an energy phosphate donor
and to turn imp into gmp you use atp
as a energy phosphate donor so that's
one
way you regulate this but the other
thing is if you have enough amp
well don't try to make amp and you have
enough gmp
don't try to make gmp and so there's
feedback there as well
that add to balancing the amp and gmp
pools what about pyrimidines well
pyrimidines simpler synthosynthesis
simpler regulation if you have enough
pyrimidines
enough ctp don't do the first step
where you take aspartate and carbonyl
phosphate
and generate that first step um
here in pyrimidine synthesis
dntps obviously as i said is
particularly critical because once you
start
replicating your dna you always have to
have the right balance of
deoxyribonucleotides
and so ribonucleotide reductase that
enzyme
up there that basically balances and
synthesizes
your deoxyribonucleotides it has
incredibly complex feedback mechanisms
that one could spend a whole lecture
talking about
but effectively it has various feedback
mechanisms with allosteric
sites and other feedbacks that are still
honestly being worked out
um that in the end is a way that helps
you balance to make sure you have the
right levels
of all the different um
deoxyribonucleotides in the end
all right if you're interested
more in the feedbacks of ribonucleotide
reductase these are covered well in your
textbook
any of the topics that we didn't have
time to cover
that might become relevant for your
future endeavors in biology medicine
metabolism whatever all of those are
well
covered and hopefully if you could
absorb some of the
concepts that i tried to impart to you
about how metabolism works
you can understand those pathways better
hope you enjoyed 705 hope you enjoyed
learning about
metabolism and thank you
very much for your attention
you